There are many different species of penguin,
and while our minds might take us to those
living in the Antarctic tundras, freezing
feet isn’t something every penguin has to
contend with.
In fact, there are some species of penguin
living on the equator that need their feet
to be cool to help them battle the heat.
For the poor penguins who do live in lands
of snow and ice, freezing isn’t usually
an issue.
Most of their body is covered in plumage that
is waterproof, which keeps them warm even
in the chill of an arctic breeze.
Emperor penguins, probably the most recognizable
species, have one of the highest feather densities
of all birds, with about 100 feathers per
square inch.
Underneath that cozy plumage is a layer of
blubber that acts as an additional blanket.
With these two layers, penguins typically
can stay toasty warm.
However, heat does escape from two main areas:
the beak and the feet, but this can actually
be a good thing.
By having areas that heat can readily escape
from, penguins are able to regulate their
temperature, keeping them from overheating
at times.
In addition to acting as temperature control,
penguin feet are bare for other reasons as
well.
Penguins need them to grip the ice and help
to steer when they are swimming in icy water.
To answer your question less generically,
penguins have a highly developed circulatory
system that is able to control how warm their
feet actually get.
There are arteries in the penguins’ legs
that are able to adjust blood flow to the
feet based on temperature.
The arteries restrict blood flow when it’s
colder, meaning less blood has to travel through
the cold feet, helping to keep the penguin
warm.
(Humans actually can do this to some extent
as well.)
When the penguin is too warm, the opposite
happens and the arteries allow more blood
blow to the feet, cooling them off.
Besides this built in mechanism, a more mundane
way the penguin can control their feet’s
temperature is simply to huddle down around
their feet so that their body is keeping them
more protected and warm.
They also sometimes rock back and sit on their
tails for a while to get their feet off the
ice.
Typically with this heat regulation, the penguins’
feet are kept a few degrees above freezing,
and not usually much warmer than that so that
the penguins don’t expend too much energy
in heating their feet, unless they are already
too hot, in which case the loss of heat is
a good thing.
Energy is of particular concern to Emperor
penguin dads who incubate their eggs for 64
days away from the coast and don’t eat anything
during this time—so, preserving calories
by not losing much heat is a must!
The good news is, with their circulatory system,
their feet won’t be turning into ice blocks
unless their stored food situation
gets critical.